yeah welcome to this video and what am I
going to play let's play the caro-kann
doing this video series far as you see
and like to practice some of the lines
in fact that just today did a video
they're just going to be released in the
next couple of days on on this this
specific line and I got this just a week
ago I saw in a 15 minute game and I
thought well I never saw this move it
probably is some some fishy a non
theoretical line but I looked this up
and in fact them this seems quite okay
for black okay this is some this is ram
they all take so I'm what now okay of
course I can just take on c3 and some
shouldn't be too bad yeah let's let's do
that what now I can go g6 or maybe I
also have some some other ways to to
develop a five maybe five yeah probably
just place d takes d5 maybe then I can
play deform okay man this is probably
maybe this is complete nonsense but it
looks interesting my idea was it takes
on e5 and then then I go deform its
looks of it I know it looks slightly
like ever I'll bean counter gambit or
something but
yeah now Queen a5 this was was my
intention that this queen is putting
pressure on c3 and on the E and E five
but Bishop c5 with the tempo and maybe
the rookie six Bishop b6 and Ruby aid
yeah let's just try that I mean it's not
the most them obvious way to play this
position and probably not the best but
it's interesting and therefore worth a
shot maybe okay so 92 on cavett the c3
porn which is a good thing but it also
um somehow doesn't help the whites
development yes I know but isn't this
risky i mean Bishop d7 and so on be 57
will be six also a move not a bad move
just attacking f2 and how does he defend
it 94 I play Queen B 2 and wider serve
as a neutral not bad really but Bishop
d7 also was I was quite interesting and
tending Bishop c6
but this is just just good i think he
doesn't have a good move to defend f2s
Knight d4 Queen B to a so just excellent
attacking the rook enter the porn on c3
yeah probably probably needs to do
something like that it's a really ugly
move but maybe it is forced okay open up
against the f2 don't want to spend too
much time taking rook takes is just
curtains on f2 and I'm threatening to
take you five so am probably needed to
do that this however I can just take any
question is is there something better
maybe the move G fire phasis is good
what about rook e8 maybe rook e8 and
takes on on a six with the rook yet one
not too much time
so how to continue here and can play g5
and take on on c4 it's a simple and good
maybe I'm maybe they are better moves I
don't I don't see ya see at the moment
this is also interesting and put on need
to play move at some point okay come on
keep keep it simple this just leads to a
good good position not sure how good but
it is it is better for black threatening
her to to put pileup on the e-file he
cannot cancel and if he takes b7 I
simply can't yeah he just I just takes I
cannot believe that this is working got
the rook e8 rook be to all kinds of
moves now threatening would be to how
does the untangle here it would be
really crazy a few managers
yeah but book p 1 oh this is so he Sam
he has covered this pure coincidence but
he has covered it but wait when when
when when wait for take rook rook be one
king d to rock da check 94 there isn'ta
where nothing goes crazy ok oh man I
must be the absolute most stupid idiot
ever that is a win yet I don't see it I
don't see the when I'm such an idiot its
unbelievable at least it's a draw with
13 seconds on the clock but this is was
just this is embarrassing i mean this
must be completely over I mean mate or
or winning a piece of something so this
is in fact ok this is also ok Bishop f2
okay and just Bishop f2 ok yeah well
give me some seconds but this is this
yeah but I cannot win in 13 seconds
anyway but of course I can I should
should play it this is this is easy
and I want this like he has this this
little trick this makes and make sure
the game go on but okay but I mean how
all this this is just just so terrible
well the computer likes my my moves but
it simply looks like there should be
some maid or something oh just rupee one
I need to I need to stop the sash this
session here Rep completely playing like
a complete idiot look here just just
this one and I was only thinking rookie
to and then see for saying what I can
simply take care of course and this and
this wins wins apiece for for absolutely
nothing and very easy to play also so
okay just take this game as an exercise
and find a winning position a winning
move and every kind of position and
probably you find improvements on all my
moves thanks for watching this